she was the first female firefighter in
the new york fire department on 9 11.
when the terrorist attack the now
retired firefighter said she knew
exactly what she had to do tamsen fidel
has her story
you know i was one of the lucky ones
on 9 11 i was a survivor and i think
it's important that everybody remember
that it was the greatest rescue effort
on american soil in our history
and it remains to this day two decades
later the memories of september 11th are
still fresh for former firefighter
brenda berkman we're desperately seeking
anyone who might still be alive and you
know it was like working in a field of
razor blades because basically all the
concrete and glass have been pulverized
when the buildings fell down burkman was
off duty september 11 while waiting for
transport to ground zero she and her
fellow firefighters watched the south
tower fall on television when they
arrived in manhattan workman remembers
that all the firefighters on scene were
immediately put to work i want people to
know that we tried our best to find
anything related to anyone that was lost
down here to try and give the family
some kind of peace she worked on side
almost every day in the wake of the
attack by april of 2002 she was one of
only two assigned officers there there's
a lot of
sorrow that i have that's connected with
this place now we're tired workman's
projects all have a connection to the
day we will never forget from
volunteering with other female 9 11
survivors to her art project 36 views of
one world trade center 343 firefighters
were killed in one day and i just want
to repeat that number 343
and 23 new york city police officers and
37 port authority police officers and
countless numbers of other uniformed
folks who
would run here to try and help however
they could this trailblazing firefighter
says it is the resilience and tenacity
of new yorkers including the first
responders and essential workers who
came to the rescue that day and have
continued to give hope throughout the
pandemic we need to honor them we need
to understand
and and commemorate everything that
happened accurately and then we need to
build back better like we have down here
at
the world trade center in lower
manhattan i'm tamsen fidel